action the modern worship inspection
said if I gave notice the total number
of routes all for each candidate
election was a scholars marine pelvis
Scottish National Party snd 27,000
megan gallagher Scottish Conservative a
nebulous 3695 last year Scottish Liberal
Democrats 601 Frank Ryan studies leave
about the 50,000
1289 there were 42 rejected ballot
papers and the percentage hall was 68 or
seven percent the total would pass
before the 8279 and I hereby declare the
candidate elected to serve and the
United Kingdom Parliament a lot of
worship in Section C is Martine fellows
well I don't think I'm going in much
lifting but an excuse I try to find the
returning officer and always done all
the hard work Norman's United for the
past few weeks to make sure elections
went smoothly and feeling I'd also like
to thank all the other person helping
the democratic process run smoothly
across the constituency so the
caretakers challengers and police
Scotland thank you all I'd also like to
find all the other candidates and in my
Troy for making this a fear and positive
campaign to my campaign team I thank you
for everything you've done you are truly
inspiring people each and every one of
you I won't start to list each and every
one of you individually i believe all
night but i always always appreciate
your kindness and friendship i received
during this campaign you all who you are
but there is one member of my campaign
team like
personally the bottom of my heart my
erection agent my son George
but most of all I'd like to find the
people of the skin statue and say who
voted for me yesterday each poetry is a
precious thing and so it's a privilege
and an honor to have your support thank
you all for your face at me and an SNP
thank you for making me the first ever
female minimalist in stock
and for telling you a few years of
Scotland's future I will represent
everyone in this constituency to the
very best my ability this election is
about making the voice of the people
mother will worship and counsel the for
Scotland heading back to play at
Westminster than ever before I pledge to
be a little champion for our communities
this is a promise i look forward to
delivering it if genetically related
homesite a strong group lesson p.m. geez
we will work really hard to put an end
to their strategy cuts which are hurting
people in communities north and south of
the border
there's a promise to start on the
referendum starting the door switch with
the biggest impact and getting more
people into our an agent work p as part
of soda of SNP MP i will always vote
against wasting 100 billion on a new
generation
Jim stop excited we can choose to invest
in the things that really monitor two
people in Scotland biker National Health
Service in 1945 the people of mother
will be elected the first ever Scottish
National Party member of parliament dr.
Robert McIntyre I'm really delighted to
follow in his footsteps tonight I'm
harder to gain the trust of the people
here to be a member of parliament I
promise I will work hard for you I'm
going to let you down thank you